[Musique]
la 54e édition du salon de l'agriculture
a ouvert ses portes samedi 25 février à
paris porte de versailles et pour dix
jours
et comme chaque année la réunion et
représentait le village agricole
réunionnais est installée dans le
pavillon outre-mer et une dizaine
d'exposants sont présents pour
promouvoir l'agriculture réunionnaise et
les savoir-faire pays
cette année près de 15 tonnes de
produits ont été acheminés jusqu'à la
capitale depuis le début de la matinée
juste un fait goûter aux visiteurs
mangue fruit de la passion longanis et
ananas
on prépare nos fruits on les envoie par
avion les arrive ici on a mis vendredi
après midi
on apporte un petit bout de la réunion
sur le stand d'à côté marie rose
diffusait les senteurs de la réunion
avec ses huiles essentielles de bourbon
là la plus grosse partie de l'huile
essentielle de géranium et voilà la
parfumerie métropolitaine on garde un
petit peu pour les autres militaires
et puis aussi pour les touristes qui
viennent à la réunion donc et c'est
vraiment l'a conduit fin avec une
moyenne de 700 mille visiteurs le salon
et pour le département
la chambre d'agriculture et libertés un
rendez vous incontournable pour mettre
en avant la richesse et la qualité de la
production réunionnaise
nous avons une vraie ambition sur
l'agriculture et lance avec l'ensemble
des partenaires et les interprofessions
la réunion ce sont des paysages de canne
à sucre avec une filière qui produit la
valeur ajoutée
sur des déçus aujourd'hui reconnue dans
le monde entier comme le meilleur sucre
de l'océan indien
voire même le club est un produit
européen et il y a aujourd'hui sur cette
île une volonté d'aller plus loin avec
de l'agro nutrition
avec aussi des produits de qualité comme
la vanille bourbon les huiles
essentielles tout ce qu'on appelle les
niches et qui peuvent produire même au
niveau des plantes médicinales et du
savoir faire et de la valeur ajoutée
pour la règle lors de l'inauguration du
village réunionnais les élus ont
également tenu à rappeler la nécessité
de soutenir la filière agricole la
réunion et les autres dom nous avons nos
propres diversité nous avons des
spécificités qu'on ne retrouve pas en
bretagne ou encore sur les régions
aquitaine la réunion guadeloupe
martinique encore guyane nous avons
sommes des territoires spécifiques et
pour ses spécificités
il nous faut être à l'écouté il faut
entendre et il faut surtout comprendre
comment fonctionne l'agriculture dans ce
département d'outre-mer
nous profitons de notre passage à paris
pour effectivement multiplié les
contacts multiplié les rendez vous pour
montrer qu'à la réunion et avec
l'ensemble des pays d'outre-mer
nous sommes capables de défendre nos
produits et notre production
en plus des stands des dégustations et
quelques animations musicales sont
également prévues sur le village le
salon international de l'agriculture se
poursuit jusqu'au 5 mars prochain
[Musique]